express the rational number 19 over 27
or 19 27 as a terminating decimal or a
decimal that eventually repeats include
only the first six digits of the decimal
in your answer let me give this a shot
so we want to
we want to express 19 over 27 which is
the same thing as 19 divided by 27 as a
decimal so let's divide 27 into 19. so
27
going into 19 and we know it's going to
involve some decimals over here because
27 is larger than 19 and it doesn't
divide perfectly
so let's go into get into this so 27
doesn't go into one it doesn't go into
19 it does go into 190.
and it looks like 27 is roughly 30 it's
a little less than 30 and 30 times 6
would be 180 so let's go with it going
six times let's see if that works out
well 6 times 7 is 42
6 times 2 is 12 plus 4 is 16
and when we subtract 190 minus 162
is going to guess actually we could have
had another 27 in there because when we
subtract
so we get a 10 from the tens place so
that becomes eight tens this became 28.
so we could have put one more 27 in
there so let's do that
so let's put one more 27 in there
so 7 27s 7 times 7 is 49
7 times 2 is 14 plus 4 is 18.
and now our remainder is 1. we can bring
down another zero
we can bring down another zero 27 goes
into 10 0 times 0 times 27 is 10
subtract we have a remainder of 10 but
now we get to bring down another zero
so let's bring down this zero right over
here
so now 27
it goes into 100 three times
three times 27 is 60 plus 21 is 81
81 3 times 7 yep 21 got 81 and then when
we subtract 100 minus 81 well we could
take a hundred from the hundreds place
and make it ten tens
and then we could take one of those tens
from the tens place and make turn it
into ten ones and so nine minus nine
tens minus eight tens is equal to 110
and then 10 minus 1 is 9. so it's equal
to 19 you probably you might have been
able to do that in your head
and then we have and i see something
interesting here because we bring down
our next zero
we see 190 again we saw 190 up here but
let's just keep going so 27 goes into
190 we already we already played this
game it goes into it seven times seven
times 27 we already figured out was 189.
we subtracted you had a remainder of one
then we brought down another zero
bring down another zero we said 27 goes
into ten
zero times zero times 27 is zero
subtract then you have
still have the ten but we got to bring
down another zero
we got to bring down another zero so if
27 goes into 100 we've already done this
three times so you see something
happening here it's
0.703703 and we're just going to keep
repeating 703 this is going to be equal
to 0.703703703703
on and on and on
forever so the the the notation for
representing a repeating decimal like
this is to say this is 0.703
and you put a line over the part that's
going to repeat so you put a line all
over the 7 the 0 and the 3. so this
means that the 703 will keep repeating
on and on and on so let's actually input
it into the exercise now
so
it's
0.703
7
0 3 and they tell us to include only the
first six digits of the decimal in your
answer and they don't tell us to round
or approximate because obviously if they
said round to that that's that smallest
six the decimal place then you would
round up because the next digit is a
seven but they don't ask us to round
they just say include only the first six
digits of the decimal in your answer so
that should do the trick
and it did